oui alors moi je suis pas trop concerné
parce que mes enfants sont tout petit
mais madame bd mais a voulu absolument
que je pose cette question mais j'ai
réécouté me lave ou des filets mais en
coulisse vous avez vraiment insisté
impossible que fait que faire lorsqu'on
se rend compte que notre enfant sur les
sites pornographiques
[Rires]
il ya bien des clés un enfant d'ailleurs
c'est un jeune homme qui va avoir 18 ans
si la réponse est très simple vous
prenez mon bouquin vous ouvriez j'ai
tout s'achète vie consacrée qu'il faut
faire dans ce cas là il va tous les gens
pas encore lu donc si vous pouviez
répond je crois qu'il avait sérieusement
c'est un problème gravissime vous savez
que l'âge du premier contact jeu moyen
du premier contact avec la pornographie
ses 9 ans maisons neuves en me voilà
donc je suis un début de mon bouquin je
me suis fixé comme but le fait de
traiter les parents pour qu'ils puissent
jouer le rôle de pare-feu par rapport à
ce danger que constitue la pornographie
mais qu'est ce qu'on fait on fait
l'autruche on dire non non j'ai pas vu
ce qui se passe on va désamorcer les
choses en discutant je me suis rendu
compte que tu as fais là c'est juste des
conseils pratiques pour les parents qui
se posent des questions et qui souvent
n'osent pas aller vers ce terrain
sélections c'est très difficile parce
que comment comment aborder de la
question parle de la fellation
or il faut savoir aussi qu'en sixième
c'est un acte qui se pratique assez
couramment mais même qu'il soit dans
cette situation c'est amusant 11 ans et
qui se pratiquent de façon tarifées
alors là je ne sens pas très bien mais
alors pardonnez moi non mais c'est vrai
que c'est bon ça nous fait sourire mais
c'est extrêmement grave vous dites donc
dès l'âge de 9 ans et le c'est le
premier pas si j'ose dire pour lui qu'on
est gamin je fais tout le temps il se
fait avec un sens on va sur internet
parce que les images viennent bien tu
avoues presse quand j'allais dire sur
les semaines des uns et des autres et
ses six mois par an je me rends compte
que mon enfant a été soumis à ces à ces
images qui peuvent être très violente
pour un gamin de 9 10 11 ans comme enjeu
désamorce je lui explique que ce n'est
pas la vraie vie je lui explique que ça
se passe pas comme ça que c'est ça que
ça s'appelle du cinéma et je pointe les
choses crûment du doigt je crois je
crois qu'il faut pas partir il faut pas
avoir peur des mots
attendu le faire il faut vraiment dire
voilà ça se passe pas comme ça entre
papa une maman c'est autre chose voilà
c'est tout à fait exagéré on montre des
choses qui sont carrément répugnante
parce que il ya des gens que ça excite
donc mais c'est pas c'est pas fait pour
les sanctions qu on en parle il faut un
vrai ça me paraît impératif d'accord
trina également très bien écrit et très
bien expliqué surtout qu'il est préfacé
par brigitte lahaie avec qui je
travaille donc je ne vais pas critiquer
mais parfois la peur de voir ça ouais
vraiment ça me met mal à l'aise et
j'aimerais savoir que ce qui me laisse
d'avoir lu mon livre certaines questions
qui seront abordées dans le dossier peut
mettre mal à l'aise et j'aimerais savoir
pourquoi il faut justement absolument
parler de sexualité aux enfants pourquoi
il faut absolument leur en parler parce
que les adolescents on se comprend la
prévention évidemment c'est très
important mais les enfants pourquoi vous
n'avez pas peur que ça allait enfin ça
les choque un peu je pense que on vit
dans une époque qui a complètement
changé de registre de repères il ya
encore vierges avaient un patient qui me
parlait de ce qu'il avait fait quand il
faisait ans en sang il avait demandé des
renseignements à ses parents qu'il doit
faire carrément l'afrique le petit
larousse sur la sexualité et les parents
l'ont remercié dans merci nous a ôté une
épine du pied parce qu'on n'a pas su
quoi aborder comment aborder le problème
aujourd'hui nous les parents on est
devancé par cette machine de guerre qui
s'appelle la pornographie donc il faut
il faut à tout prix de faire quelque
chose on peut pas laisser faire et ce
que vous dites c'est que effectivement
peut-être que les parents de cette
nouvelle génération sont confrontés les
enfants sont beaucoup plus jeunes
confrontés à ces plus les adolescents
auparavant effectivement à qu'on
attendait les questionnements à 14 15 16
ans là les questionnements peuvent venir
dès 7 8 novembre
tout à fait oui et